[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren ja die Kolleginnen Jeanette Clark
hat es schon gesagt wir melden uns aus
der westlobby des Deutschen Bundestages
und wir begrüßen bei dieser Gelegenheit
nicht nur die Zuschauerinnen und
Zuschauer von Phoenix sie sind ja
sowieso immer bei uns um diese Zeit und
wenn Bundestag ist sowieso sondern auch
die Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer des rbb
auch Ihnen herzlich willkommen schön
dass Sie mal bei uns sind und das ganze
hat durchaus einen Grund und da sind und
Verstand denn wir wollen Sie hier ein
klein wenig vorbereiten auf die Rede des
Königs Charles des dritten hier im
Deutschen Bundestag es wird sein zweiter
Auftritt sein im Bundestag insgesamt
2020 im November hatte hier schon mal
eine Rede gehalten allerdings natürlich
als Prinz und damals war das Ganze an
einem Volkstrauertag da ging es auch um
die Deutsch politischen Beziehungen und
die gemeinsame Deutsch politische
Vergangenheit heute also der erste
Auftritt des Königs im Deutschen
Bundestag als König und alle sind ganz
gespannt wie denn die Rede wohl
ausfallen wird von Charles dem dritten
denn das Programm dass er bislang auf
der Agenda hatte das hat doch in vieler
da Hinsicht auch in Richtung Ökologie
und Zukunft der Erde grüne Energie
hingedeutet so dass wir neben den
deutschen britischen Themen durchaus
auch den einen oder anderen Hinweis in
dieser Richtung erwarten wie der
königsbesuche in Deutschland bislang
verlaufen ist das hat die Kollegin
Valerie Krall zusammengefasst und da
schauen wir jetzt kurz mal rein
ja und dann habe ich die Kollegen jetzt
ein klein wenig überrascht oder ich die
Kollegen je nachdem wie man das ganze
sieht wir haben ein paar Bilder
vorbereitet gehabt von der Ankunft des
Königs beim Bundeskanzler der König hat
ja eine ganze Reihe von Terminen heute
zu absolvieren hat vor dem Treffen mit
dem Bundeskanzler bereits die Regierende
Bürgermeisterin getroffen hier von
Berlin und sich ins Goldene Buch
eingetragen und ähm wie gesagt
anschließend der Bundeskanzler getroffen
es wird keine besonders lange
Besprechung sein weitere Termine dann
nach dem Besuch hier im Bundestag der
rede hier im Bundestag dann unter
anderem in Brandenburg im berühmten oder
gut bekannten hier zumindest in der
Region bekannten Ökodorf Brodowin und
jetzt kommen wir sozusagenfassung des
gestrigen Tages ein Beitrag von Valerie
Krall
Jubelrufe für den König
vor großer Kulisse am Brandenburger Tor
Charles und Camilla werden vom
Bundespräsidenten Frank-Walter
Steinmeier empfangen
danach Händeschütteln mit den Berlinern
Charles sichtlich gut gelaunt dass in
seine erste Reise als König nach
Deutschland führt
entscheidet die britische Regierung
vielleicht würde er auch gern mal einen
Strandurlaub machen aber so läuft das
nicht
zu Deutschland hat Charles aber eine
besondere Beziehung er spricht die
Sprache er hat Verwandte dort es ist
also eine großartige Gelegenheit für ihn
am Abend auf Schloss Bellevue
prominenter auf Galopp das König Charles
noch vor seiner Krönung zu Besuch kommt
wird mit einem Staatsbankett gewürdigt
vor mehr als 100 Gästen betont er wie
wichtig ihm die Freundschaft zu
Deutschland ist und das sogar auf
Deutsch
wenn wir gemeinsam auf einer
nachhaltigere Zukunft in wortstand und
Sicherheit hinarbeiten
heute wird Charles dann noch im
Bundestag sprechen eine große Ehre denn
er ist der erste Monarch überhaupt der
hier eine Rede halten darf
und das ist nicht der einzige Termin der
heute den König in Berlin erwartet es
gibt noch zwei weitere die ich durchaus
noch erwähnen sollte die ich vorhin noch
nicht genannt habe beispielsweise wird
er im ehemaligen Flughafengelände Tegel
am ehemaligen Flughafen oder eine
Flüchtlingsunterkunft besuchen und er
wird dann außer dem noch den
Wittenbergplatz hier in Berlin
Schöneberg besuchen da freuen sich auch
schon eine ganze Reihe von Leuten drauf
der andere relativ groß sein und wir
werden gleich noch die Gelegenheit haben
hoffe ich zumindest mit unserer Kollegin
Katharina kühn zu sprechen die nämlich
vor Ort ist und das ganze Geschehen aus
aller nächster Nähe beobachten kann was
das Thema aller Nächte Nähe angeht will
ich ihn Renate Künast nicht vorenthalten
die hat den König in früheren Zeiten als
er noch Prinz gewesen ist natürlich
wiederholt getroffen unter anderem in
ihrer Zeit als sie gerade
Landwirtschaftsministerin geworden war
im der im Bundeskabinett und hat sich da
auch schon gepflegt ausgetauscht zum
Thema Ökolandwirtschaft
vieles was darum noch dazu gehört und
mit ihr hatte ich vor wenigen Minuten
die Gelegenheit zu sprechen und dieses
Interview spielen wir Ihnen jetzt zu
Frau kühners hatten sie die Chance oder
haben Sie die Chance noch mit dem König
zu sprechen hier also ich erlebe ihnen
diesmal nur hier im Plenum gleich und
bin voll freudiger Erwartungen irgendwas
muss ja gesendet werden dort und ich
denke das wird nicht nur der Besuch
eines Repräsentanten eines Staates
sondern er ist ja so ein bisschen grüner
König ja selber öko-bauer hat sich mit
Architektur mit jungen Menschen und
ihrem Lebenschancen beschäftigt also
warte ich auf ein paar sind Stifte Sätze
ich habe das natürlich nicht ohne Grund
gefragt sie kennen ähm Charles noch als
Prince natürlich wir haben ihn
wiederholt getroffen und sie haben auch
ausführlich über Öko-Landwirtschaft und
ähnliche Dinge gesprochen wie ist der
Kontakt das erste Mal zustande gekommen
auf eine ganz witzige Weise ich war
gerade Ministerin geworden und
traf den Geschäftsführer der Soil
Association von Großbritannien das
sozusagen der Ökolandbau Verband der
auch zertifiziert da ist damals Prinz
Charles Eon Präsident und irgendwie hat
sich da ein Gespräch ergeben und als ich
erwähnte ja ich gucke ja auch immer was
er macht als öko-bauer sagte mir Patrick
Holden ja the prince hat auch schon
gesagt oder gibt's ja in Deutschland
eine interessante neue Ministerin die
plötzlich über Ökolandbau über Natur und
so in Verbindung mit Landwirtschaft
redet dann hat er gesagt na ja wenn sie
auch interessiert sind organisiere ich
was unten ein halbes Jahr später war ich
in Highgrove zu t&q Converter Sandwiches
darüber hinaus einige Male getroffen
auch in Deutschland glaube ich bei der
Eröffnung der der britischen Botschaft
war das gab sie dass die Leidenschaft
ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel aber
das Interesse an der königlichen Familie
gab es das schon vorher oder ist das
erst dadurch entstanden bei ihm weil man
muss dazu sagen sie ist große Sammlerin
von Bechern mit Royal Family Motiven ja
also eigentlich hat sich das als
absolute Marotte ergeben der dass ich
immer in einer Zeitung aus aller Welt
las was britische Königshaus und meine
Wohngemeinschaft sich darüber lustig
machte dann brachte mich mir jemand aus
England so ein Mark so eine Kaffeetasse
mit mit Emblem drauf ich fing dann
selber an zu sammeln bis ich irgendwann
gesagt habe so ungefähr bei zehn jetzt
reicht es brauchen wir keiner mehr was
schenken also ich habe das
Silberjubiläum der Queen die Verlobung
Diana Charles und so weiter ein ganzes
Sortiment davon und ich habe dann aber
auch immer interessiert gelesen er ist
ja angeeckt also mit seinen ganzen
Vorstellungen beim Ökolandbau oder dass
man sagt er spricht mit Pflanzen obwohl
jeder Gärtner jede Gärtnerin das auch
intuitiv macht ne habe ich dich an die
falsche Stelle gepflanzt oder so ist
eigentlich auch schon Gespräch er hat
alte
hafenbereiche und und Häuser umbauen
wollen und sich in Architektur
eingemischt in London
Blogs auch weil er sagte das soll doch
vielleicht was für junge Leute werden
die wenig Perspektive haben das habe ich
halt alles immer gelesen und ich weiß
das allererste Mal dass ich ihn traf war
noch als Berliner Landtagsabgeordnete da
gab es einen Empfang hier und er war
kurz vorher in Kanada gewesen und hat
dann immer über rikschars geredet er
hätte im Montreal oder irgendwo würden
überall Rikschas rumfährt und das wäre
doch auch was nettes hier und Sie können
sich vorstellen in den 80er guckten alle
so was hat er da jetzt wieder für eine
Idee ist doch kurios jetzt fahren hier
ricksaft große Touristen Aktivität ja
dann haben sie getroffen unter anderem
sie haben sie eben gesagt als sie gerade
Landwirtschaftsministerin geworden waren
wie tief ist er drin in diesem Thema aus
ihrer sich kommt man da richtig auf
Ebene mit dem sich austauschen
also sie glauben es ja nicht ich war
auch erstaunt wenn er dann gleich anfing
über die europäische
gradzahlungssysteme und die
Direktzahlung und die ökozahlung also
erste zweite Säule und so weiter er ist
da hat da schon Vorstellung davon was
wofür ausgegeben wird und weiß diese
Zahlen auch auswendig oder Kriterien
auswendig also wonach geht man wonach
richtet man sich aus ist schon ein
qualifiziertes Gespräch und er ist für
viele in der Szene bis nach Deutschland
rein auch eine
Identifikationsfigur weil wo gibt's das
schon hat es damals gegeben dass in
einem so berühmten Königshaus jemand
sich für den Naturkreislauf interessiert
ja er hat auch hier viele Termine die
mit diesem Thema zu tun haben
beispielsweise heute besuchte noch ein
Ökodorf
Wien hier in Brandenburg hat
in Hamburg glaube ich auch einen Termin
wo sie zumindest und Green Energy geht
also um grüne Energie also hat dieses
Thema schon sehr oben hoch auf die
Agenda gesetzt denken Sie dass es ihm
als König noch mehr gelingen wird
dieses Thema oder für dieses Thema noch
mehr Interesse zu wecken jetzt hat er 70
Jahre auf das Amt gewartet ja hat das
Thema durchgehalten dass ich überzeugt
bin jetzt kommt eine Änderung er wird
sich nicht mehr so öffentlich explizit
äußern können ich bin für oder gegen
aber er wird einfach durch seine
Anwesenheit das Thema heben wie sie
schon sagten also er geht in diese
ökodorf-produ Wien
und interessiert sich für andere
Energieform und so das sind ja Bilder
und das ist auch eine Botschaft und wenn
sie am Brodowin denken alle Berliner
Berlinerin kennen das weil die als viele
z.B Milch und Käseprodukte von denen
gibt die hier verkauft werden oder auch
Gemüse und da ist das der Ortsname ist
schon die Marke ja und das ist übrigens
ein toller Arbeitgeber in der Region die
bilden aus sie haben 110 voll
beschäftigte Menschen dort so also das
ist ja eine Aussage dass man damit im
Einklang mit der Natur sein kann und
Beschäftigung bringen und der Witz ist
es liegt ganz in der Nähe vom Kloster
Chorin schon fein
Reservat kultureller Ort als altes
Zisterzienserkloster heute gibt es ein
Konzerte und wenn sich ein König da
mitten reinstellt in diese Szenerie ist
es eine Botschaft das ist so danke an
die Leute die da aktiv sind aber es ist
eben auch eine inhaltliche Botschaft
darüber nachzudenken so wie wir jetzt
darüber reden wahrscheinlich gucken
jetzt alle Leute wo ist das vielleicht
auch mal hin abschließend Frau kühners
was erwarten sie von der Rede die ja
hier halten wird es ist ja seine zweite
im Deutschen Bundestag schon
Volkstrauertag 2020 hat er hier schon
mal gesprochen aber heute natürlich eine
andere Perspektive und eine andere Rolle
jetzt ist der König jetzt ist der König
und der wird natürlich quasi auch im
Auftrag der britischen Regierung hier
das Interesse darstellen die Beziehung
zwischen Deutschland und Großbritannien
und Deutschland der EU weiter auszubauen
man leidet ja unter dem Ergebnis des
brexit jetzt muss man sich wieder neu
zueinander finden vielleicht auch
wissenschaftsbasis Jugendaustausch wird
der eine Punkt sein und dann hoffe ich
dass er sich mit dem Thema
Lebensgrundlagen auseinandersetzt also
muss ja nicht so eng über öko-bauer sein
aber dass wir alle unsere Zukunft heute
bearbeiten was wir heute tun entscheidet
über in 10 20 30 Jahren und dann muss er
eigentlich was setzen und wir werden
live dabei sein Ihnen für den Moment
vielen Dank Frau kühnerst
die Bundestagsabgeordnete Renate Künast
ist gespannt auf die Rede des Königs
hier um 12 soll es soweit sein wenn wir
noch ein paar Bilder kriegen vorher von
der Ankunft hier am Reichstagsgebäude
dann werden sie die natürlich sehen aber
wir nutzen auch die Gelegenheit uns noch
ein bisschen weiter zu unterhalten über
dieses Thema und dem Besuch des Königs
und wir können das machen mit Kai
witteker Abgeordneter der
cdu/csu-fraktion Mitglied im Ausschuss
für Arbeit und Soziales aber wir haben
ihn heute vor allem natürlich eingeladen
wegen seines Namens und dieser Name hat
einen Grund ihr Vater ist Brigitte so
ist es ähm er und seine Familie kommen
aus Großbritannien ist dann nach
Deutschland in den 70ern gekommen hat
meine Mutter kennengelernt und jetzt
darf ich Deutscher und Brite sein und
haben natürlich den Entwicklungen in der
letzten ja insbesondere sieben Jahre
seit dem brexit natürlich sehr scharf
verfolgt wie ist das in dieser Rolle
deutscher und Brite zu sein wenn der
König des einen Landes kommt na
emotional ist das ein bedeutender Tag
das gebe ich zu das wird heute bewegen
für mich quasi meine grünen
Staatsoberhäupter in einem Raum zu sehen
und darauf freue ich mich sehr ich
glaube es ist auch ein wichtiges Zeichen
dass die erste Reise des britischen
Königs ausgerechnet nach Deutschland für
das sollten wir wertschätzen wenn ich
schon ein bisschen überraschend ich
freue mich natürlich für sie aber sie
sind in Baden-Baden glaube ich auf
geboren und aufgewachsen also gut ihr
Vater ist Brite aber trotzdem ist er
trotzdem so eine emotionale Nähe auch zu
dem anderen Land ja weil ich natürlich
dort Familie habe ich habe auch die
Gelegenheit in meinen jungen Jahren
genutzt in Großbritannien zu studieren
war meine Option vielleicht auch
komplett zu leben damals war es ja noch
cool Britannia das lange her und ähm
habe mich aber dann entschieden in
Deutschland mein Leben zu führen und
freue mich jetzt dass sie natürlich auch
für Deutschland hier im Deutschen
Bundestag sitzen darf arbeiten darf
neben der Freude und den Emotionen mit
welchen Erwartungen schauen Sie auf die
Rede des Königs hier im Parlament wer
ist ja schon seit gestern da hat ein
paar Punkte und ein paar wildmarken
schon mal gesetzt aber wenn man mal
gucken er hat ja auch schon mal hier als
Prinz im Parlament geredet wird wenn sie
auf diese Rede gucken die um 12 kurz
nach 12 Uhr wahrscheinlich beginnen wird
was erwarten Sie ich glaube dass er
schon bei aller Vorsicht die er
natürlich walten lassen muss als nicht
Politiker
ein Akzent setzen wird neu ein neues
Kapitel in der deutschen britischen
Freundschaft aufzuschlagen die letzten
Jahre waren geprägt durch den brexit sie
waren schwere Jahre
und ich glaube Großbritannien möchte
jetzt wieder eine Annäherung an die
Europäische Union und das ist natürlich
Deutschland die ersten Nationen an die
sich Großbritannien auch wendet und ich
finde wir Deutschen sollten Sie gut
beraten wenn wir die Tür nach Europa und
auch insbesondere in die EU für Briten
immer offen halten
Frankreich gewesen wo er zuerst gewesen
ist aber die wären dort und die Proteste
zur Rentenreform
hierhin verschlagen aber es wird
tatsächlich immer wieder betont auch von
ähm reden man sei ja nach wie vor
europäischer also man sagt man nicht
mehr in der EU aber man sei ähm wenn man
sein wie gesagt noch Europäer geograph
wünsche auf jeden Fall auch stimmt wie
nah sind uns die Briten denn noch
politisch nach dem brexit politisch
wohlgemerkt ja ich glaube dass sie uns
schon sehr nahe sind das merken wir zum
Beispiel im diesem furchtbaren Krieg in
der Ukraine die Briten sind eine der
stärksten Unterstützer der Ukraine
liefern Waffen liefern Munition liefern
Geld und humanitäre Hilfe waren einen
der ersten Nationen in Europa die das
getan hat und hat natürlich auch für uns
Deutsche einen Weg mit geebnet ebenfalls
mit zu tun und zu helfen in der Ukraine
und insofern sind die Briten eine
führende Nation gerade wenn es um die
europäischen Werte geht aber ich glaube
es macht sich auch eine gewisse
Ernüchterung in Großbritannien nach dem
Werk sind breit dass es eben nicht die
großen
wohlstandsversprechungen jetzt erfüllt
sind
und der britische Premierminister ist
unter Druck seine Wirtschaft wieder
anzukurbeln und dazu braucht er
natürlich enge Handelsbeziehungen mit
der Europäischen Union und da braucht er
natürlich auch das Gewicht Deutschlands
sie haben vorhin gesagt die Deutschland
und auch die EU täten gut daran die Tür
offen zu lassen für die wahrscheinlich
halten sie es denn dass die Briten die
Tür von sich aus bzw wieder betreten
würden oder durch die Tür wieder
durchgehen wollen zumindest mal so als
Idee oder muss man da vielleicht noch
ein paar Jahre warten bis dieses ganze
Trauma brexit was ein sehr langer und
teilweise auch sehr quellender Prozess
gewesen ist einigermaßen überstanden ist
sicherlich keine Frage in den nächsten
Jahren aber als der brexit Abstimmung
war haben wir in deutschen Bundestag
darüber gesprochen ich durfte da auch
für meine Fraktion reden und ich habe
das ganz bewusst am Ende gesagt ich
hoffe dass ich vielleicht auch noch in
meinem Leben erlebe dass die Briten
wieder Mitglied der Europäischen Union
werden und die Stimmung hat sich in den
letzten Jahren deutlich verändert weil
einfach eine nüchterung eingekehrt ist
es gibt noch keine politische
Bereitschaft bei irgendeiner Parteien
Großbritannien zu sagen es war ein
Fehler wir müssen zurück in die
Europäische Union aber der Prozess hat
sicherlich angefangen haben sie noch
heute noch eine Gelegenheit ihr noch bei
anderen Gelegenheit noch mal zu sehen
oder heute nur hier im Parlament und da
kommt man von seinem Platz natürlich
nicht weg ich habe ihn heute nur die
Gelegenheit den Plenum aber morgen ist
er ja noch in Hamburg und dort bin ich
auf Bitten der britischen Botschaft
ebenfalls eingeladen und da freue ich
mich schon sehr drauf vielen Dank
wünsche dir viel Vergnügen mit der Nähe
zumindest zum König und die Kolleginnen
und Kollegen haben mir gerade gesagt wir
haben ein paar Bilder tatsächlich jetzt
live vorliegen auf die wir vielleicht
sogar noch mal gemeinsam gucken können
denn der König ist gerade vorgefahren
hier vor dem Reichstagsgebäude des
Deutschen Bundestages wir sehen da aber
noch vorhanden da sehen wir ihn sogar
mit drin einigermaßen Bedienstete des
Bundestags natürlich drumherum und
natürlich auch Sicherheit und jetzt
müsste müssen wir ein bisschen auf die
Bilder gucken genau die
Bundestagspräsident ist natürlich schon
bei ihm jetzt der Weg in den Bundestag
hinein dann scheint das ja jedoch alles
ziemlich pünktlich über die Bühne zu
sehen Camilla natürlich auch dabei wir
haben zwischendrin meine Damen und
Herren auch immer wieder schon gesehen
einem Blick auf die Besuchertribüne des
Deutschen Bundestages die heute
natürlich auch außergewöhnlich prominent
besetzt ist mit beispielsweise den
früheren Bundestagspräsidenten Thierse
dem ich gesehen habe oder auch den
früheren Bundespräsidenten Gauck also
jede Menge Prominenz da auch auf der
Tribüne aber will schauen dann gleich
auch noch mal zurück nein jetzt sind die
Bilder wieder weg dann sage ich noch mal
vielen Dank Herr Rüdiger dass sie da
waren viel Spaß heute noch mit dem
Besuch demnächst reden wir wieder
bearbeitet und Soziales komme ich auch
nicht drumherum irgendwie und wäre auch
ein Zusammenhang mit Großbritannien
durchaus sein hoch interessantes Thema
danke Ihnen einen schönen Tag und mit
dem König wenn auch nur aus der Ferne
danke Ihnen und wir meine Damen und
Herren Damen und Herren haben ihn vorhin
schon mal gesagt dass wir natürlich auch
am Wittenbergplatz hier in Berlin
Schöneberg vertre ten sind wo ähm der
königliche zu Gast gewesen ist und für
uns ist Katharina kühner und die Frage
an sie muss natürlich sein wie groß ist
denn eigentlich das Interesse der
Berlinerinnen und Berliner am König in
Schöneberg
ja das Interesse ist sehr groß es war
hier ziemlich eng zwischendrin als König
Charles und Camilla hier lang gelaufen
sind ich habe dort mit meinen unter 160
kaum was sehen können und es ist
natürlich hier aber auch ein bisschen
eng jeden Donnerstag findet hier der
Brandenburger Bauernmarkt statt wo eben
sich hier 60 Händler zeigen wir sehen
auch jetzt noch ist es sehr eng und hier
ihre Waren anbieten und König Charles
interessiert sich ja auch schon seit
Jahren für die ökologische
Landwirtschaft das ist eins seiner
herzensystem er hat ja selber einen
Bio-Bauernhof über 35 Jahre lang gehabt
dort auch ökologische Produkte angeboten
unter anderem die Haferkekse sollen da
ja interessant gewesen sein und wir
sehen hier auch verschiedene Stände zu
verschiedenen Ständen gegangen ist er
hat sich den honigstand angeschaut
Bärlauch wurde extra ins Englische für
ihn übersetzt
oder auch hat er sich anscheinend Käse
schenken lassen aus dem Spreewald unter
anderem aber auch mit dem Fischhändler
hier hat er sich unterhalten und sich
dann angeschaut was hier in auf dem
Wittenbergplatz so angeboten wird
und einer der Stände bei denen er war
das können wir jetzt nämlich auch
schauen das ist nämlich der honigstand
den haben wir eben auch schon mal
gesehen und Martin Perschke hat eben mit
dem König gesprochen was war denn das so
für ein Gespräch von Imker zu Imker kann
man ja sagen eigentlich ganz kurz ne und
nur mal so guten Tag und probiert ne
ganz kurz ne und ein Geschenk bekommt
vom König ne und dann war auch schon
wieder weg gewesen sein Mann kurz mal
und man kann es nicht mal angucken
kommen ne und kann man mal zu Besuch
kommen wollte eigentlich was aber ich
habe es ihm geschenkt mit dem Körbchen
vorbereitet gehabt ne
also der König hat selber auch ähm eine
Imkerei kann man sagen
können Sie gleich noch mal erzählen und
dann noch mal zeigen was genau hat er
ihnen denn geschenkt königlichen Honig
nee von königlichen Feldern denke ich
mal ne also wo steht
Garten hier ist ne
und was haben sie dem König denn
geschenkt haben sie ja gesagt mit ein
Glas Sonnenblumen und ein Glas
okay sie ja
Brandenburger Sonnenblumen und
Brandenburger Akazie oder Rubine wie man
noch sagt ne ist hier bei uns ganz
typisch ne sie haben mir vorhin erzählt
seit 20 Jahren sind sie schon Inhaber
der Imkerei und machen das auch seit 20
Jahren ökologisch
wie viele wie viele Bienen haben Sie
denn und warum haben sie gesagt ich
möchte gerne das ökologisch führen sie
können Sie auch konventionell machen
mit dem Imkerei schon vor drei
Generation zuvor ne und da hatten wir
halt sehr viel immer mit ihm zu tun
gehabt und dann hat man sich entschieden
die Imkerei mal zu machen und man hat
mal Praktikum machen ökologischen
Landbau und da haben wir das übernommen
und seitdem
ganz schön schneller Besuch kurzes
Gespräch nur was glauben Sie was bringt
das denn für den Standort oder auch für
den Markt auf dem Wittenbergplatz wenn
man so kurz so ein König aus England
vorbei schneiden
mehr Kunden ne weil es waren lässt doch
stagniert ne und mal gucken doch mehr
mehr dass mehr Leute kommen von Berlin
ne und tun hier ihren Wochen Einkaufen
hoffen wir sehen vielen Dank Martin
Perschke soweit hier vom Wittenbergplatz
vom Markt hier geht jetzt das Geschehen
langsam wieder los der war nämlich dann
doch ziemlich viele Stunden gesperrt das
heißt hier waren auch so ein paar
Passanten die wollten eigentlich ihren
Pflaumenkuchen zum Frühstück holen
konnten das dann nicht jetzt kann man
hier langsam wieder einkaufen gehen ist
normalisiert sich und damit würde ich
sagen geben wir zurück in den Bundestag
denn da ist ja man jetzt in
Ausnahmezustand
danke danke Katharina ja es ist
erstaunlich ruhig hier in der West Lobby
das ähm
plenarsals der Plenarsaal eben im
Deutschen Bundestag aber wir können
natürlich ein Blick werfen ihnen den
Saal hinein das viel interessanter als
ich es bin und wir schauen wer da schon
alles angekommen ist und sich die
Gelegenheiten nutzt auf einen kleinen
schwarz und wir sehen vor allem auch
noch Bilder die sie natürlich schon sehr
viel schneller gesehen haben als ich
hier Bilder von dem Eintrag ins
Gästebuch des Deutschen Bundestages da
haben wir den König Charles den dritten
mit
Königs Gemahlin Camilla und die
Bundestagspräsidentin Bärbel Bars wird
das auch mit großer Freude betrachten
das bedeutet wenn dieser Aktien zwischen
vollzogen ist ne das ist sogar noch live
sehe ich gerade aber nichtsdestotrotz
muss man feststellen dass das ganze
Programm ist schon ziemlich präzise
getaktet ähm gestern schon mit dem mit
der Ankunft hier in Berlin mit dem
Flieger dann die
ätherischen Ehren auf dem Pariser Platz
die wir auch live begleiten durften für
Sie das war alles schon ziemlich prima
im Zeitplan und jetzt gehen wir davon
aus dass das auch hier ziemlich
pünktlich ist das ganze jetzt haben wir
fünf vor zwölf aber sie sehen der
Eintrag ins Gästebuch des Deutschen
Bundestages ist auch schon vollzogen und
die Erwartungen bei den Parlamentariern
die sind ziemlich groß wenn wir in den
Plenarsaal gucken bis auf eine Fraktion
die hatte gestern ähm bei den
verschiedenen Gelegenheiten und auch in
einzelnen Interviews doch mitgeteilt
dass sie von diesen Besuch des
britischen Königs im Deutschen Bundestag
im Parlament also in der Volksvertretung
so überhaupt nicht Zeitung und das ist
die Linksfraktion und auch deren
Vorsitzender Martin scherde waren der
ist heute im ein und anderen Interview
noch mal gesagt hat dass man als Linke
überhaupt nichts davon hält dass der
König hier spricht dass das ganze auch
mit Völkerverständigung zu tun hat dass
das ganze auch mit
Frieden und Freund damit zu tun hat
könnte man jetzt noch anfügen und
möglicherweise dagegen argumentieren
aber es gäbe sicherlich das eine und
andere Argument der Linken dann noch in
dieser Stelle dagegen was Sie vielleicht
nicht ganz so deutlich hören wir dafür
aber umso lauter das ist das Klingeln
das hier zu vernehmen ist und mit diesem
klingeln werden die Abgeordneten in der
Regel dann in den plenarsa gerufen wenn
es um Abstimmungen geht aber hier ist
jetzt auch noch mal sehr deutlich
signalisiert worden
dass es in Kürze losgeht wir werfen
einen Blick auf die Tribüne noch mal und
sehen die beiden ehemaligen
Bundespräsidenten Wulff und Gauck hier
im angeregten Gespräch vertieft wir
sehen auch ziemlich viele Minister auch
die bundesratsbank gesehen in den
früheren Bundestagspräsidenten tierse
wir haben viele Mitglieder aus dem
Bundesrat auf der bundesratsbank auch
schon gesehen auch die gut besetzt und
natürlich die Ehrentribüne die ich schon
wiederholt erwähnt habe schauen wir dann
noch mal in den Plenarsaal insgesamt
außerordentlich gut gefüllt und alles
andere wäre ja auch kein Wunder müssen
noch mal vielleicht genauer darauf
achten wie es auf der Seite der
Linksfraktion aussieht ob sich da
tatsächlich die ganze Fraktion mehr oder
weniger verweigert hat oder ob sie
nachher im stillen Protest einfach das
ganze hier zu Kenntnis nimmt und sich
dann den Applaus spart wir werden das
Sehen und für sie beobachten da haben
wir den einen und anderen Minister die
eine und andere Ministerin auch für
diese für dieses Kabinett wird die
Veranstaltung hier heute im deutlich mit
blumengeschmückten Plenarsaal des
Deutschen Bundestages auch eine
willkommene Abwechslung sein nachdem was
hier in den vergangenen zwei drei Tagen
alles stattgefunden hat in Sachen
Koalitionsausschuss und grangel
innerhalb der Ampel Koalition Friedrich
Merz der Vorsitzende der Unionsfraktion
auch sehr entspannt im Gespräch mit
Dorothee Bär schauen wir doch mal wenn
wir noch sehen Renate Künast mit der wir
eben schon die Gelegenheit zum Gespräch
hatten im Gespräch mit Konstantin Notz
ja die Rede so heißt es im Vorfeld wird
soll ungefähr 20 Minuten lang sein davor
wird die Bundestagspräsidentin in den
Gast begrüßen im Plenarsaal dann wie
gesagt ungefähr 20 Minuten Rede es ist
und ein kleines Geheimnis wie viel
Deutsch Charles den Reden wird am Anfang
hieß es der Wolle die Rede komplett auf
deutsch halten da sind glaube ich aber
auch die die zuständig sind für diese
Veranstaltung hier heute nicht mehr so
ganz überzeugt und deswegen ist
sicherheitshalber auf dem Plätzen
beispielsweise auf der Bühne sind schon
Kopfhörer verteilt worden für eine
Übersetzung der Rede des Königs wir
haben gesehen die Linksfraktion ist in
Teilen hier natürlich trotzdem präsent
im plenarsa Gregor Gysi haben wir
gesehen Karin live beispielsweise werfen
jetzt einen Blick in die Unionsfraktion
das ist sehr gut besetzt das Parlament
und alle Herren der Dinge drei Minuten
sehe ich ungefähr sind es auf der Uhr
noch wenn es hier Schlag 12 losgehen
sollte womit ich tatsächlich rechne
und ja der Terminkalender ist auch
relativ gut getaktet wenn man das so
sagen kann wir haben schon gesagt heute
morgen war König Charles III
beispielsweise
in einem mit einer in einer kurzen
Begegnung mit Berlins noch regierender
Bürgermeisterin Franziska Giffey hat
sich ins Goldene Buch der Stadt
eingetragen danach ging es relativ zügig
weiter zum Bundeskanzler für einen
kleinen Austausch auch dazu hatten wir
ihn ja ein paar Bilder gezeigt dann
rüber zum Wittenbergplatz was zum Glück
nicht ganz so weit ist und was natürlich
unter diesem besonderen Bedingungen dann
auch schnell erreichbar ist ganz einfach
weil die Straßen dann drumherum
unterwegs dahin gesperrt wird und dann
kann die Kolonne mit dem König und
seinem Gefolge natürlich da relativ
zügig ankommen die Schöneberger werden
aufatmen wir haben es eben von Katharina
kühn gehört wenn die ganzen Absperrungen
und Sicherheitsmaßnahmen jetzt höher
wieder aufgehoben werden und da wieder
alles sein geregelten Gang gegangen
werden kann 11 Uhr Wittenbergplatz wie
gesagt und inzwischen ist der König im
Reichstagsgebäude eingetroffen wir haben
die Bilder gesehen vom Eintrag ins
Gästebuch des Bundes noch ein früherer
Bundestagspräsident nämlich Norbert
Lammert übrigens gerade noch zu
erhaschen gewesen
während die Kamera jetzt wieder
geschnitten haben auf die Regierungsbank
mit dem Verteidigungsminister mit zwei
staatsministern im Kanzleramt im
Vordergrund die Außenministerin ist
natürlich da und viele viele andere ich
glaube eigentlich sind alle Verben
und jetzt
können wir die könnte ich Ihnen jetzt
das ganze Kabinett noch vortragen weil
die sind tatsächlich hier vollständig
versammelt abgemeldet hat sich keiner
wir können vielleicht noch mal auf den
ähm auf ein paar Punkte gucken die heute
im Laufe des Tages noch auf der Agenda
stehen des Königs und seiner Gemahlin
ihr habt ja schon gesagt irgendwann im
Laufe dieser Übertragung ca 12:50 Uhr
sollte er Besuchen im ehemaligen
Flughafengebäude im ehemaligen Flughafen
Tegel eine Flüchtlingsunterkunft und von
da geht es dann weiter nach einer
Mittagspause
zum sogenannten Ökodorf brodo wen
während wir noch mal zwei
alt-bundespräsidenten sehen wo der eine
gar nicht so besonders alt ist nämlich
Christian Wolf und
Präsident Gauck im Gespräch hier jetzt
wieder die Regierungsbank mit den
mit unter anderem Gesundheitsminister
Lauterbach dem wieder kurz noch
gesehen hatten wir warten alle hier auf
den Gong der dann anzeigt dass es hier
tatsächlich los geht noch mal zwei
Ministerpräsidenten der CDU aus Sachsen
Michael Kretschmer und Hendrik wüst aus
Nordrhein-Westfalen und sie haben
vielleicht den Gong im Hintergrund
gehört und sie haben auch gesehen dass
sich die ähm Leute im Bundestag jetzt
erhoben haben und aufstehen und da ist
er König Charles III in Begleitung von
Bundestagspräsidentin Bars auf dem Weg
ins Plenum gefolgt von Bundespräsident
Steinmeier und Camilla
und dahinter der Bundeskanzler
daneben wenn die Gattin des
Bundespräsidenten und jetzt beginnt die
Veranstaltung die zweite Rede von
Charles im Deutschen Bundestag in Kürze
nachdem er 2020 ja schon mal hier
gewesen ist
Majestäten sehr geehrter Herr
Bundespräsident sehr geehrte Frau
Büdenbender Exzellenzen sehr geehrter
Herr Bundeskanzler sehr geehrter Herr
Bundesratspräsident sehr geehrter Herr
Präsident des Bundesverfassungsgerichts
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen liebe
Gäste
eure Majestät es ist uns eine große Ehre
sie im Deutschen Bundestag zu begrüßen
im Namen des gesamten Hauses heiße ich
Sie die Gemahlin Königin Gemahlin und
ihre hochrangige Delegation sehr
herzlich willkommen
auf der Tribüne begrüße ich außerdem
zwei frühere Bundespräsidenten Herr
Gauck und Herr Wulf seien Sie auch
herzlich willkommen
ebenso begrüße ich viel ehemalige
Parlamentspräsidentin und Präsidenten
liebe Frau Süßmuth liebe Frau Bergmann
Pohl lieber Herr Thierse und lieber Herr
Lammert sein auf Sie herzlich willkommen
in Anwesenheit so vieler hochrangiger
Gäste unterstreicht ist die Bedeutung
der deutsch-britischen Beziehung
eure Majestät zum Volkstrauertag 2020
sprachen sie hier vor einem ausgewählten
Publikum als Prinz of Wales heute
sprechen Sie vor dem Deutschen Bundestag
als König und als Repräsentant einer der
ältesten Demokratien der Welt
zugleich präsentieren wir im Bundestag
eine besondere Ausstellung zur
Verfassungsurkunde der Frankfurter
Nationalversammlung
1848 49
ein schlüssel-dokument der deutschen
demokratiegeschichte diese Ausstellung
erzählt auch von einem Stück Deutsch
britischer Geschichte
nach der gewaltsamen Auflösung der
Nationalversammlung wurde die
Verfassungsurkunde von einem mutigen
Abgeordneten nach Manchester in
Sicherheit gebracht und so für die
Nachwelt gesichert
dies ist nur eine kleine Episode aus der
langen gemeinsamen Vergangenheit unserer
Länder im 20 Jahrhundert war die
deutsch-britische Geschichte eine
Geschichte der extreme
Großbritannien hat ein unverzichtbaren
und großen Beitrag zur Befreiung Europas
vom Nationalsozialismus geleistet
dafür sind wir alle zutiefst dankbar
unvergessen bleibt auch
Großbritannien war ein Zufluchtsort
vieler Verfolgter in den Wochen und
Monaten nach dem november progrom 1938
nahm die Briten tausende jüdische Kinder
auf sie waren oft die einzigen in ihren
Familien die überlebten
Majestät auf ihre Initiative hin
erinnert am Bahnhof Liverpool Street ein
Denkmal an diesen Akt der Menschlichkeit
bei meinem großbritannienbesuch vor
wenigen Wochen habe ich einige der
geretteten getroffen und ich kann sagen
es hat mich tief bewegt auf der Tribüne
begrüße ich Lisa bechner sie leitet
einen Verein der sich für die Erinnerung
an die Kindertransporte einsetzt Frau
bechner herzlich willkommen
nach dem Krieg unterstützte
Großbritannien die Aufnahme der
Bundesrepublik in die westliche
Gemeinschaft und förderte die Demokratie
der erste ausländische Gast der im
Bundestag sprach war der Leiter einer
Delegation des Unterhaltes
in seiner redet worden seinen deutschen
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das eine
erfolgreiche zu einer Demokratie vor
allem etwas braucht nämlich Humor
Großbritannien wurde uns Deutschen zum
Freund und unterstützte die
Wiedervereinigung auch das vergessen wir
nie
dieses Parlamentsgebäude symbolisiert
unsere Freundschaft in besonderer Weise
es war ein britischer Architekt der das
Reichstagsgebäude umbaute
ist das Wahrzeichen des Deutschen
Bundestages Lord Foster bezeichnete sie
einmal als einen Leuchtturm der ich
zitiere Signale aussendet vom Prozess
der Demokratie
Majestät viele Deutsche bewundern die
britische Kultur und Lebensart mit
großem Respekt erinnern Sie sich auch an
ihre Mutter Zeit ihres Lebens hat sich
Königin Elisabeth II für die Aussöhnung
unserer Länder eingesetzt
im Jahr 2000 war sie gemeinsam mit ihrem
Vater Prinz Philip auch hier im
Deutschen Bundestag und hat die Kuppel
besucht
Großbritannien und Deutschland sind und
bleiben enge Verbündete und
vertrauensvolle Partner auch nach der
Entscheidung Großbritanniens die
Europäische Union zu verlassen die
Menschen in unseren Ländern sind
verbunden durch Reisen und Handeln
kulturellen und intellektuellen
Austausch oft auch durch wechselseitige
Faszination
unsere Parlamente pflegen enge Kontakte
unsere Regierung arbeiten eng zusammen
in vielen Organisationen und Formaten
Großbritannien und Deutschland treten
gemeinsam für eine regelbasierte Ordnung
ein wir stehen solidarisch an der Seite
der Ukraine in ihrem Kampf für Freiheit
und Selbstbestimmung wir teilen
gemeinsame Werte und das Interesse die
Herausforderungen unserer Zeit
entschlossen anzugeben
nirgendwo ist es so dringlich wie bei
der existenziellen Aufgabe für die auch
Sie sich schon seit langem einsetzen den
Kampf gegen den Klimawandel und für den
Erhalt unserer natürlichen
Lebensgrundlagen
unsere gemeinsame Verantwortung für die
Zukunft betonten sie auch vor drei
Jahren in ihrer Rede beim Volkstrauertag
2020 sie sagten zusammen sind wir eine
unverzichtbare Kraft für das Gute in
unserer Welt heute brauchen wir diese
Kraft mehr denn je eure Majestät sie
haben das Wort
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Herr Bundespräsident
sehr geehrte Frau
Bundespräsidentin meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren
es ist ein großer Ehre heute bei ihnen
zu sein
meine Frau und mir bedeutet es sehr viel
dass wir auf meine ersten
Auslandsreise als König nach Deutschland
eingeladen würden
und vor allem dass ich hier sprechen
darf um das Bekenntnis so Freundschaft
unsere Länder zu erneuern
es gibt kaum einen besseren Ort dafür
dass dieses Gebäude dessen Steine die
Geschichte des 20
Jahrhunderts erzählen
es demonstriert selbst was unsere beiden
Länder verbindet
1933 in Brand gesetzt
1945 schwer beschädigt würde es in den
neuzinger Jahren von einem britischen
Architekten zu palment des
wiedervereinigten demokratischen
Deutschlands umgebaut
die
ikonische Glaskuppel ist ein Simba für
die Transparenz und recht rechenschafts-
von hier aus können die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger ihren Politikern tatsächlich bei
der Arbeit zu selten
Demokratie
meine Frau und ich
dürften bereits im November
anlässlich des fuchsfrauentags hier im
Bundestag zu Gast sein
es war mir sehr wichtig 55 Jahre nach
dem Zweiten Weltkrieg an der Seite der
deutschen alle Opfer von Krieg und
Törner
und als erstes Mitglied meine Family an
diese bewegenden Gedenkfeier
teilzunehmen
ihre Einladung damals zeigt wie weit das
Vereinigte Königreich und Deutschland
auf dem Weg der Freundschaft und des
Friedens gekommen sind
Sie Herr Bundespräsident haben die
schönen 2018
so ein druckswahl bewiesen mit ihrer
Teilnahme am gedenken zum hundertsten
jastag des Endes des Ersten Weltkriegs
in London
der Freundschaft zwischen unseren
Ländern zu erneuern
[Applaus]
diese Freundschaft hat meine geliebten
Mutter der Verstorbenen Königin viel
bedeutet
sie hat oft gesprochen über ihre 15
offiziellen Besucher in Deutschland
unter denen auch fünf Staatsbürger
im Jahr 1965 fand in einer Zeit statt in
der der Kontinent noch von tiefen
Nahrung des Krieges und dem Trauma des
Konflikts geprägt war
Generation meine Mutter gehört
und wie mein Vater hatte sie in
ungeformt
Deutschlandreise meiner Eltern sich als
entscheidender Moment in der Versöhnung
zwischen unseren Nationen haben sollte
daher für beide große persönliche
Bedeutung
meine Mutter wusste
wirkliche und mit ihren vielen Besuchern
in Deutschland wird sie ihren Beitrag
dazu leisten
vielleicht
ist das der Grund warum sie sich einen
besonderen Platz in Herzen der deutschen
Roboter
meine Family und ich waren zutiefst
berührt von der Reaktion Deutschlands
nach dem Tod meine Mutter
die bereits Bekundungen aus dem
Bundesstaat das Brandenburger Tor in den
Farben des Union Jack und die vielen
tausend Einträge in kondolenzbuche im
ganzen Land
all das war uns in den Seiten der Trauer
ein großer Trost
im Namen meiner gesamten family danke
danke ich Ihnen von ganzem Herzen für
die
außerordentliche
Anteilnahme der Menschen in Deutschland
Herr Bundespräsident
Frau Bundestagspräsidentin
beseitigt das letzte Mal hier gesprochen
habe ist die Geißel des Krieges zurück
in Europa
der Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine
hat unser
verstellbares Leid über so viele
unschuldige Menschen gebracht
salose leben werden zerstört
und
Menschen wird Freiheit und Menschenwürde
würden brutal mit den Füßen getreten
die Sicherheit Europas ist ebenso
bedroht wie unsere demokratischen Werte
aber die Welt hat nicht tatenlos
zugesehen
wir sind erschüttet konnte fruchtbaren
zerstören
aber wir können Mut schöpfen aus unserer
Einigkeit
so Verteidigung der Ukraine
des Friedens und der Freiheit
[Applaus]
Deutschland und das bereinigte
Königreich haben eine wichtige
Führungsrolle übernommen
aus größte europäische gebe für die
ukrai Ukraine haben wir entschlossen
reagiert und Entscheidungen getroffen
die früher vielleicht
unvorstellbar gewesen wäre
der Entschluss Deutschlands der Ukraine
so große militärische Unterstützung zu
kommen zu lassen ist überall mutig
wichtig und willkommen
[Applaus]
unsere pilotten
fliegen gemeinsame Einsätze im Luftraum
unsere patischen Partner
hier in Deutschland haben unsere Amin
ein gemeines gemeinsames
pionier-brückenbeteiligung aufgestellt
dass ich heute Nachmittag
besuchen werde
[Applaus]
Deutschland ist das ein
Siegerland weltweit mit dem das
Vereinigte Königreich einer starke
gemeinsame Einheit unterhält ein
außerordentlicher Beweis für unsere
Partnerschaft
lesen Gentleman eigen beginnt
ich kann kaum in Worte fassen ich stolz
ich auf die starke Partnerschaft unserer
beiden Länder bin
Deutschland seine Menschen und seine
unverwechselbare Kultur haben im Laufe
meiner Familie suche einen tiefen
Eindruck hinterlassen
seit ich mit gerade einmal 13 Jahren zum
ersten Mal nach Deutschland kam
dieses bemerkenswerten Landes
kennengelernt
persönliche Verbindung
hierhere Beziehungen die mir teuer sind
und die Generationen zurückreichen
alle verbindet das sind die unzähligen
Berührungspunkte und gemeinsamen
Erfahrungen der deutsch-britischen
Geschichte die sich über fast zwei
Jahrtausende erstreckt
im Mittelalters lieferte die berühmte
waren aus Lübeck und Hamburg zu helfen
an der englischen Küste sie etablierte
so eine handelspartnerschaft die bis
heute unseren gemeinsamen Wohlstand
begründet
flossen auch Ideen
und die Menschen ließen sich voneinander
inspirieren
wir entwickeln eine gegenseitige
Bewunderung für unsere Literatur und
Musik
Deutsch war die erste Sprache in die
Shakespeare übersetzt würde
und die erste Shakes der Gesellschaft
der Welt würde
1864 nicht etwa in England gegründet
sondern den Weimer
[Applaus]
[Musik]
in wenigen Wochen werden wir bei der
krönungsfeier in der westenste RB wieder
großartige Werke von Georg Friedrich
Händel Hirn der als deutsche geboren
wurde und als Britzer starb
so wie bei jeder grünen seitdem meines 7
maligen Urgroßvaters
des Schrecken 1727
sind die Menschen viel hin und her
gereist zwischen
jahrhundert verliebten sich viele Briten
auf ihrer Grand Tour in Deutschland
Tennis
faszinierende Gemälde von Ansichten des
Rheins in seinen Landsleuten den Wunsch
diese Landschaften selbst zu sein
sollte der Pionier des Tourismus Thomas
Cook später erfüllen
erstmals rein Reise
Stationen in Köln Frankfurt
lebendige Kultur und das Nachtleben in
Berlin
die größte europäische Besuchergruppe in
dieser wunderbare Stadt
wir bewundern also noch immer
gegenseitig unsere Kultur sind
wirtschaftlich voneinander abhängig und
lassen uns von den Ideen der anderen
inspirieren
denken dabei vielleicht nicht nur
oder eher an die Bibel oder ein
Kraftwerk
er an die Beatles oder Kraftwerk als ein
Brahms oder Bayern aber das Netz unserer
kulturellen Verbindungen ist so stabil
und was vielleicht am wichtigsten ist in
den letzten 50 Jahren haben wir viel
zusammen gelacht sowohl übereinander als
auch miteinander
[Applaus]
also hoffentlich kein korrektes Bild des
modernen Großbritannien vermittelt
gehört es doch wie ich weiß zu einem
deutschen
Großbritannien hat uns Deutschlands
comedy-botschafter Henning Wehen einen
Eindruck in die Eigenheiten der
deutschen verschafft genau wie Monty
Python Ihnen die unsere Gnade gebracht
hat
[Applaus]
wie unter guten Freunden übrig erlaubt
die Herzlichkeit unserer Beziehungen
manchmal ein kleines Lächeln auf Kosten
der anderen
natürlich gibt es auch Rivalität ich
denke da besonders an die Begegnungen
zwischen uns und Fußballmannschaft
vor diesem Hintergrund war es etwas ganz
Besonderes dass die englische Frauen
Fußballmannschaft die leihen es ist mit
einem Sieg gegen Deutschland
Europameister würde
[Applaus]
über dem sportlichen Erfolg hinaus haben
bei der Mannschaften auf eindrucksvolle
Weise für die gleiche Erstellung der
Geschlechte gewürbe
so haben sie eine ganze Generation
inspiriert
in Großbritannien Deutschland und auf
der ganzen Welt
das ist
nur ein Beispiel dafür wie unsere Länder
ein leuchtendes Vorbild für die Welt
sein können
erfreulicherweise gibt es noch viele
weitere solcher Beispiele
konfrontiert mit so vielen gemeinsamen
Herausforderungen übernehmen das
Vereinigte Königreich in Deutschland
eine Führungsrolle zur Sicherung unserer
gemeinsamen Zukunft
Deutschland sind heute die beiden
größten Produzenten von offshore Windows
in Europa
viele deutsche Unternehmen sind an der
Herstellung und Installation von
Turbinen vor der britischen Küste
beteiligt
unsere Menschen seit Generationen Reisen
und Handeltreiben
die uns einen direkten Handel mit Strom
ermöglicht
Aufbau unserer Wasserstoffwirtschaft
voran ein Ressource die unsere Zukunft
transformieren könnte und ich freue mich
darauf zu erfahren wie Hamburg diese
Technologie einsetzen will um seinen
Hafen komplett nachhaltig zu machen
solche Innovationen sind unverzichtbar
um die uns alle betreffende
existenzielle Herausforderung des
Klimawandels und der Erderwärmung zu
bewältigen
ich habe mich gefreut gestern von
Teilnehmern des Berlin energy transition
Dialog zu hören
diese Wende vorantreiben
seit langem sind die britische und die
deutsche
wissenschaftliche Forschung wegweisen
beide Gründung von erfolgreichen neuen
technologies nehmen wir europaweit die
ersten beiden Plätze ein
zwischen unseren Universitäten und
Forschung sind sie Tüten gibt es mehr
Kooperationen als zwischen jedem anderen
Länderpark in Europa
so rüstet in ein Berliner Unternehmen in
London Laternenmasten auf um sie als
Ladestationen für
Elektrofahrzeuge zu nutzen
und in Berlin kann man sich in einem
vollelektrischen Londoner Taxi durch die
Stadt fahren lassen
auch auf internationale Ebene arbeiten
wir eng zusammen auf der Klimakonferenz
in Glasgow haben wir zusammen mit
Südafrika die just energy transition
mitbegründet
ein eine weitere sollte Partnerschaft
mit Indonesien war das Ergebnis einer
intensiven Kooperation während der
deutschen die sieben Präsidentschaft
Bundestag
zwischen unseren beiden Ländern beruht
auf den können Engagement und
einfallsreich tun unzähliger Menschen
sowohl in Deutschland als auch im
Vereinigten Königreich
und von ganzem Herzen danken
Gedenken an der Seite der Menschen in
Deutschland stehen
in Hamburg werde ich am Denkmal für die
Kindertransporte die vor 85 Jahren mehr
als 10.000 jüdische Kinder vor dem
Nationalsozialismus retteten und ihnen
ein sicherer Reise in ein neues Leben in
Großbritannien ermöglichten wir haben
respektvoll
gemeinsam mit Ihnen Herr Bundespräsident
und Ihnen Herr erster Bürgermeister
Tschentscher werde ich auch der Opfer
der Bombardierung von Hamburg im Jahr
1943 durch die Alliierten gedenken
erste begangenheit zu lernen ist unsere
Pflicht aber nur durch unsere Engagement
für eine gemeinsame Zukunft können wir
sie fühlen
gemeinsam müssen wir wachsam sein
Gegenüber Bedrohungen unsere Werte und
entschlossen diese resolut entgegen zu
treten
gemeinsam müssen wir unseren Menschen
das Leben in Sicherheit und wortstand
ermöglichen dass die verdienen
die lange und besondere Geschichte
unsere beiden Länder enthält noch viele
ungeschriebene Kapitel
lassen Sie uns
diese mit einem jünemütlichen mündlichen
Streben nach einer besseren zukünft
fühlen
unsere gemeinsame Vergangenheit und die
Verheißungen unsere gemeinsame Zukunft
verlangen von uns nichts gering
[Applaus]
meine Damen und Herren vielen Dank für
Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
stehende Applaus von den
Verfassungsorganen die jetzt König
Charles und Camilla hinaus begleiten aus
dem Plenarsaal des Deutschen Bundestages
stehende Applaus auch von den
Abgeordneten des Deutschen Bundestags
wenig Applaus aber immerhin doch einige
stehen in den Rhein in der Linksfraktion
ganz eigenen schon mal erwähnt und
natürlich auch Applaus von der
bundesrats- und der Regierungsbank im
Deutschen Bundestag für diese Rede von
König Charles im Bundestag eine Rede die
die Freundschaft zwischen Großbritannien
und Deutschland an so vielen und so
unterschiedlichen Stellen immer wieder
betont hat und wenn ich mich richtig
erinnere hat es eine so große Nähe ein
so großes Wohlwollen gegenüber
Deutschland von einem ausländischen
Staatsoberhaupt in dieser warmen und
zugewandten Formen durch wie so wie es
erlebt haben durch ihre König Charles
schon lange nicht mehr gegeben worauf
hat er zurückgeblickt auf eine
schwierige teilweise aber doch lange
gemeinsame Geschichte auf kulturelle
Gemeinsamkeiten genauso wie auch für
gemeinsame Forschungsprojekte und
Vorhaben was hat er gesagt es gibt keine
zwei anderen Länder Paare in Europa die
so eng in Forschungsfragen
zusammenarbeiten wie es Deutschland und
Großbritannien machen und hat dann als
Beispiel erwähnt
unter anderem auch die
Elektrifizierung von Kraftfahrzeugen und
gesagt das ist sei ein typisch oder
nicht wenig oder wenig überraschend dass
er ein vollelektrisches Londoner Taxi
durch Berlin fahre ein kleines Beispiel
dafür dass gemeinsam geforscht wird und
wie viele auch unterschiedliche Dinge
aus den unterschiedlichen Ländern sich
gegenseitig hier
befruchtet haben
überall die Zeit gemeinsame Forschung
war das eine er hat aber dann natürlich
auch und das war wenig überraschend und
da haben auch alle relativ lange drauf
gewartet oder ich sagen zumindest etwas
länger drauf erwartet als seine
tatsächlich kam aber auch die
erneuerbaren Energien angesprochen wir
wissen das ist ein großes Thema immer
schon gewesen ist ähm von König Charles
dieses dieser Punkt den er in der
jüngeren Vergangenheit ja immer wieder
schon auch eventuell noch mal ganz kurz
in den Plenarsaal meine Damen Damen und
Herren denn da gibt es noch das eine und
andere durchaus interessante Gespräche
noch zu erherrschen bevor die Sitzung
des Bundestages vorübergehend
unterbrochen unterbrochen werden wird
und dann um 13 Uhr fortgesetzt werden
soll mit einer regulären Debatte dann
aber im Moment sehen wir noch das eine
oder andere informelle Gespräch auch mit
zweien die in den vergangenen Wochen
wahrscheinlich oder Tagen muss ich mal
korrekter Weise sagen wahrscheinlich
etwas intensiver miteinander gerungen
haben um Themen nämlich der
Bundesfinanzminister und der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister hier im
Gespräch mit der bundesbauministerin
Clara galwitz und da haben wir auch noch
mal informelle Gespräche in Rhein der
grünen Fraktion gesehen die FDP alle
sehr gelöst und ja und alle
wahrscheinlich doch ein klein wenig
angetan auch vom Besuch des britischen
Königs und das frage ich doch direkt mal
weiter nämlich den Vorsitzenden der
kommt durch ein bisschen näher an den
Tisch rein der Zimmermann den
Vorsitzenden in der deutschen britischen
parlamentar in der Gruppe hier im
Deutschen Bundestag das ist Jens
Zimmermann aus der SPD-Fraktion jetzt
sagen Sie doch mal was war denn ihr
Eindruck jetzt gerade in der letzten na
fast 40 Minuten also ich war sehr
positiv überrascht weil er es war ja
eine sehr politische Rede die der König
hier gehalten hat hätte man sich von
seiner Mutter so nicht vorstellen können
und ich glaube man muss es auch so ein
bisschen im Kontext mit der
innenpolitischen Diskussion in
Großbritannien sehen und aber ich glaube
er hat das Verbindende in den
Vordergrund gestellt und ich glaube nach
dieser Rede stehen eigentlich alle da
und fragen Sie noch ein bisschen mehr
wie konnte das mit diesem brexit
eigentlich jedem jemals passieren ich
habe vorhin ein bisschen vor schnell und
auch hatte noch wenig Gelegenheit noch
mal danach zu Kram aber ich kann mich an
keiner Erinnerung keine Rede erinnern
schon gar nicht hier im Bundestag
irgendwie wo die Nähe zu Deutschland
oder die Freundschaft zu Deutschland so
betont worden ist wie jetzt eben ja sehe
ich ganz genauso also in den letzten
zehn Jahren kann ich mich an keine auch
durchaus so persönliche und verbindende
Rede erinnern wenngleich er ja wirklich
auch auch die die dunklen Kapitel der
gemeinsamen Vergangenheit angesprochen
hat aber das hat er glaube ich wirklich
sehr sehr gut gemacht und ich denke man
spürt auch im Hintergrund ist ganz viel
in diesem Besuch reingesteckt worden es
ist sein erster Auslandsbesuch und ich
habe das auch gestern Entschuldigung ein
bisschen zufällig natürlich es ist es
spielt jetzt keine Rolle ob er zuerst in
Frankreich gewesen wäre aber es ist der
erste Auslands Trip von ihm und deswegen
im Hintergrund alle Leute die um ihn
herum daran arbeiten die an der Rede
gearbeitet haben die haben unglaublich
viel Arbeit da reingesteckt aber ich
glaube auch er hat da ganz persönlich
auch versucht Akzente zu setzen und ich
finde das ist ihm gelungen
offensichtlich auch ihm wichtig war die
die Trauer und die Anteilnahme am Tod
seiner Mutter die ja sehr ausführlich
betont hat den gleich auch zu Beginn und
auf der anderen Seite da wieder große
Heiterkeit irgendwie zu sagen wir haben
viel gelacht über aber auch miteinander
und schließlich ein ganz großes Feld der
Fußball jenseits der Politik die
Rivalitäten zwischen Deutschland und
England sind ja Legende inzwischen aber
er konnte sich auch nicht ersparen dann
zu sagen die Frauen des Frauenteam
Großbritanniens Englands um genau zu
sein dann bei der letzten
Europameisterschaft der Frauen dann im
Endspiel gegen Deutschland gewonnen hat
also daher das ist glaube ich britisch
auch oder ja total aber es zeigt
natürlich auch genau diesen Akzent zu
setzen wir haben übereinander und
miteinander gelacht das ist das zeigt
aber auch und das ist die große Chance
glaube ich für Deutschland hier auch wir
haben hier ein Staatsoberhaupt man muss
ja auch mit Kirche ein bisschen im Dorf
lassen es nicht der Regierungschef ist
das Staatsoberhaupt aber er ist jemand
der wirklich Brücken bauen kann nach
Deutschland weil er die deutsche Kultur
versteht und das passiert ja bei uns
durchaus auch manchmal dass wir die
britische Kultur meinen zu verstehen
aber so ganz klappt es nicht immer und
dann ist man doch wieder bei den
Handtüchern in Mallorca auf der Morgen
liege aber das hat er wirklich
hinbekommen und er hat ja gestern Abend
beim Staatsbank hätte auch gesagt zum
Glück ist das hier kein Dinner for One
also das hat schon gezeigt dass er da
dass er da schon auf sich viele Gedanken
gemacht hat was er eben ja auch noch mal
aufgenommen hat und was natürlich alle
sofort verstehen und alle sofort mit
England oder Großbritannien insgesamt
hast du zu ihnen so haben wir sie
eingeladen weil sie Vorsitzender der
britischen Parlamentariergruppe sind wie
steht's denn eigentlich jenseits von
solchen
persönlich sehr nahen und emotionalen
nahen reden in diesem Fall des neuen
Königs wie steht's denn um die
deutsch-politischen Beziehung sagen wir
mal auf gesellschaftlicher Ebene also
sie sind nach wie vor eng aber wir
müssen jetzt wirklich natürlich mit den
Realitäten des brexits auch umgehen und
gerade ich bin selbst ein erasmus-kind
ich bin nach Großbritannien damals
gegangen über den europäischen Studien
austauscht und der ist jetzt sehr sehr
zum Erliegen gekommen und das ist auch
ein ein Anliegen was wir als
ParlamentarierInnen Parlamentarier haben
weil nur mal eine Zahl wir sind fast 50
Abgeordnete und wir haben alle so eine
persönliche Geschichte mit
Großbritannien gibt glaube ich kaum ein
Land wo wir so enge Beziehungen haben
und wir versuchen das immer wieder klar
zu machen das ist auch für
Großbritannien ein großer Gewinn wenn es
hier viele Abgeordnete gibt die da auch
persönliche Erfahrungen haben also es
ist schwierig aber ich sehe schon jetzt
gerade auch in dieser Legislaturperiode
bei uns das ist vorangeht weil man jetzt
auch mit dem Winzer agreement wo man die
Nordirland Frage in den letzten Wochen
geklärt hat jetzt wirklich nach vorne
blicken können und das vielleicht das
Interessante ist wenn wir nach
Großbritannien fahren zu unseren
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die fangen
immer wieder mit dem brexit an weil die
müssen natürlich auch jeden Tag damit
leben und wir sagen jetzt eher wir
finden es nach wie vor schade wir
akzeptieren aber jetzt lasst mal nach
vorne schauen und darum wird es auch
gehen aber ich mein Olaf Scholz hat den
neuen Premierminister noch nicht
getroffen zu einem offiziellen Besuch
das liegt natürlich auch daran ich mein
Olaf Scholz ist jetzt anderthalb Jahre
im Amt nicht mal und hatte glaube ich
vier Premierministerin und
Premierminister in der Zeit das war
schon auch ein Problem für die Beziehung
von britischer Seite klar wenn man nicht
weiß man wie man sich dann halten soll
und vor allem wie lange der oder die
dann auch tatsächlich im Amt ist
abschließend Herr Zimmermann sie haben
den brexit ja angesprochen das ist in
absehbarer Zeit natürlich
unwahrscheinlich dass es da eine
Kehrtwende gibt dazu waren die
Verletzungen und die die Kraftverlust in
Großbritannien durch diesen Prozess auch
viel zu groß und viel zu stark
nichtsdestotrotz mittelfristig oder
vielleicht sogar langfristig können sich
vorstellen dass die Briten sich der EU
auch wieder nähern zu Europa das betonen
sie ja bei jeder Gelegenheit so Europa
fühlen sich natürlich nach wie vor
selbstverständlich zugehörig und den
Sachen Ukraine sind sie ja auch sehr
aktiv aber wie sieht's aus wieder zurück
in die EU Mittel langfristig wie lange
wird es möglicherweise dauern oder ist
es überhaupt wahrscheinlich also es wird
mit Sicherheit nicht kurzfristig
passieren aber wir wissen ja alle auch
die EU muss sich reformieren wir wollen
uns in den Richtung Westbalkan erweitern
also mit dieser Reform der EU der
Institution könnte sich aus meiner Sicht
auch eine Chance ergeben Großbritannien
wieder näher heran zu holen und die
Auswirkungen des brexits sind in
Großbritannien jetzt wirklich greifbar
die ganzen Probleme die wir hier haben
mit Energiepreisen mit
Lebenshaltungskosten die sind in
Großbritannien nochmal stärker und das
Wirtschaftswachstum ist nochmal
schwächer also man merkt dort schon das
war offensichtlich keine so gute Idee
und gleichzeitig aufgrund des Kriegs in
der Ukraine man braucht Verbündete man
ist zu klein um in dieser Welt gerade
auch Stichwort China überhaupt noch was
ausrichten zu können und deswegen bin
ich da mal optimistisch und das ist ja
auch was was die Briten haben sie haben
einen gesunden Optimismus keep kam and
carry on ist ja einer der berühmten
Sprüche und ich glaube das ist es was
wir da auch sehen werden aber der
Koalition auch mal bei Gelegenheit auf
dem Weg geben Herz immer Jens Zimmermann
ist Vorsitzender der deutschen
politischen Parlamentariergruppe ist
unmittelbar nach der Rede von König
Charles zu uns gekommen und hat den
einen und anderen Punkt mit uns noch mal
erwartet und zurückgeguckt und auch auf
die Zukunft geschaut erzähl mal meinen
vielen Dank dass Sie bei uns waren und
wir meine Damen und Herren geben
vorübergehend zurück aus dem Deutschen
Bundestag
13 Uhr sollte Debatte hier fortgesetzt
werden dann wieder mit dem regulären
Betrieb wir haben uns natürlich wieder
aber eins Weinen haben alles was noch
wichtig ist an diesem Tag und auch im
Zusammenhang mit dem Besuch des Königs
hier in Deutschland Michael Saar und ein
Gast für Sie in unserem Brunner Studio
und da gebe ich jetzt den ab ich danke
sehr Erhard und auch Herren Herrn
Zimmermann yakam und carry on das machen
wir hier auch im Studio König Charles
hat gesprochen und ein Brite der
Deutschland sehr gut kennt der
natürlichen Großbritannien geboren und
groß gewachsene groß geworden ist bei
uns im Studium Lukas herzlich willkommen
danke schön was hat er zwischen den
Zeilen gesagt
zunächst einmal fand ich dass diese
Razer Raider eine klassische charlesrede
war gewisse Maßen er hatte wenn man das
einfach so oberflächlich liest
glaube ich verpasst man schon einiges
also zum Beispiel das allererste was mir
auch viel war war dass er davon
gesprochen hat dass die Beziehungen
erneuert werden müssen ja wenn sie nicht
schlecht geworden sind dann braucht man
sie ja nicht erneuern das heißt das war
aus meiner Sicht schon ein ein kleines
Seitenhieb auf die Aktivitäten von den
Premierministern Johnson und Trust die
so viel beigetragen haben in den letzten
Jahren für schlechte Laune in den äh bei
lateralen Beziehung Beziehungen und auch
völlig unnotwendige Weise in der Frage
des nordirischen Protokolls was
natürlich ein absolutes
absolute Dorn im Auge war für die
Europäer und vor allen Dingen auch für
die Kommissionen
ist noch was aufgefallen was er durch
die Blume gesagt hat also eine leichte
regierungskritik an der eigenen
Regierung ja also er hatte auch
sehr pointiert gesagt dass unsere Länder
eine Gemeinsamkeit haben dass sie
nämlich Ordnungen haben die basieren auf
das Recht und
dass sie gemeinsame Werte haben aber wir
wissen dass beispielsweise Charles als
Prinz Charles vor einem Jahr ziemlich
heftig die Regierung kritisiert hat
wegen der Einwanderungspolitik in
Großbritannien vor allen Dingen geht es
um das Asylrecht und im Moment soll ein
Gesetz das britische Parlament passieren
was ist ermöglicht also Asylrecht stark
einzuschränken teilweise die Leute die
über den Ärmelkanal kommen als illegal
zu bezeichnen und dass diese unter
Umständen nach Ruanda geflogen werden
sollen wo ihre Asylanträge angeblich
dann bearbeitet werden aber haben dann
kein Recht auf Rückkehr nach
Großbritannien und das ist
ein klarer Verstoß gegen die Europäische
Menschenrechtskonvention und die jetzige
Regierung hat auch nicht ausgeschlossen
dass sie diese Konvention tatsächlich
verlässt das ist natürlich Sprengstoff
weil politische Politiker nach dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg zu denjenigen gehört
haben die diese Konvention
mitgeschrieben haben und angeregt haben
das heißt Charles hat es war natürlich
nicht ausdrücklich gesagt das hat
einfach durch die Blume
königlich angedeutet dass unsere
Beziehung zwischen Deutschland und
Großbritannien ist sondern aufrecht und
werden basiert sein und hat so mehr oder
weniger auf den Weg gegeben passen Sie
auf wenn sie das jetzt in der
Einwanderungspolitik nicht machen ja
seit Betriebe in das Inland und vor
allen Dingen die britische Rolle nochmal
gestärkt dann doch näher an Europa zu
sein als das bei vielen Briten
vielleicht im Moment im Kopf ist also
auch ein Appell an die Zukunft ja er hat
natürlich auch sehr viele Punkte
gemeinsame Punkte betont allen fordern
Ukraine die Unterstützung für die
Ukraine und auch natürlich die
Energiepolitik und Klimawandel und so
weiter das sieht dann natürlich große
Gemeinsamkeiten aber auch dort hatte er
einen kleinen Seitenhieb äh nicht sie
nicht verkneifen können nämlich in Bezug
auf die wissenschaftliche Kooperation
nachdem man sich verständigt hat auf die
sogenannte
winzervereinbarung Winzer agreement
damit hat man das Nord das Problem der
des nordirischen Protokolls entschärft
möchten die Briten natürlich wieder in
das horizon-programm der europ zwischen
Union kommen und das ist so etwas wo sie
natürlich die Unterstützung der
deutschen haben wollen weil die
Europäische Union hat die Teilnahme als
eine gewisse Massen als ein Faust fand
entwickelt und den Briten praktisch
durch die Blume gesagt er muss euch
Benehmen sonst seid ihr nicht dabei im
Horizon und die britischen Universitäten
müssen dann natürlich auf Milliarden
verzichten für ihre Forschungsprogramme
und das hatte ja ausgesprochen indem er
gesagt hat ja wie gut wer gemeinsam
geforscht haben und wie wichtig das ist
gerade dann die Kurve bekommen in
Richtung Klimapolitik und offshore wind
und so weiter und so weiter also war
eine ziemlich deutliche Botschaft er
möchte wieder eine Annäherung an die
Europäische Union vor allen Dingen
Deutschland und Frankreich weiß
allerdings natürlich dass er gegen den
brexit nichts machen kann das ist Sache
der Politik genau ich danke dass wir sie
im Studio haben es ist wunderbar ihnen
zuzuhören weil sie so schön durch die
Blume lesen können ist fasziniert was
sie alles noch hinter den Worten
heraushören und sehen und erkennen auch
interessant war gestern Abend viel
beachtet eine Tischrede da ist auch der
Running Gate gewesen den er heute im
Bundestag immer wieder auf das ja eher
in Deutschland bekannte berühmte dinner
for one was wir immer zu Silvester hören
und sehen und immer wieder drüber lachen
obwohl es ja ein uralter schwarz-weiß
Film ist gesagt hat hören wir rein in
seine Tischrede gestern Abend im Beisein
des Bundespräsidenten
sehr geehrte Bundespräsident
ich weiß nicht wie ich Ihnen für Ihre
überaus freundlichen Worte und für ihre
unvergessliche Gastfreundschaft in
diesem festlichen Rahmen danken soll
es ist wunderbar heute Abend in so große
Gesellschaft zu sein
und es ist schön von Ihnen dass
Sie gekommen sind und mich nicht mit
einem Dinner for one
alleine lassen
meine Frau und sich sind tief gerührt
die herzlich wir in Deutschland
empfangen würden
genau wie bei jedem unserer führen
Besuche in diesem ganz besonderen Land
ich habe festgestellt dass ich
tatsächlich mehr als 40 Mal in
Deutschland gewesen bin
darin zeigt sich natürlich wie wichtig
mir unsere Beziehungen sind aber auch so
fürchte ich wie lange es mich schön gibt
an jeden dieser Besucher habe ich
Erinnerungen an die ich sehr gerne
zurückdenke
wunderbaren Freundschaften die sie und
Frau wütenbänder meiner Frau und mir
gegenüber gezeigt haben während unseres
letzten Besuches im Jahre 2019 und 2020
ich denke da an sehr gern zurück und ich
denke auch sehr gerne an die Zeit als
wir meine Frau und ich noch bayerische
Würste Essen auf einem Markt in Bayern
und dort tatsächlich auch Bier trinken
und balzertanzen im Hofbräuhaus ich
glaube ich kann auch verstehen warum der
englische Mönch Bonifatius ähm der ja in
Deutschland gepredigt hat ein großer
Anhänger des Brauwesens war Deutschland
und das reinigte Königreich haben ein
großes Interesse an
der Zukunft des jeweils anderen Landes
unsere Beziehungen werden noch stärker
werden da waren bin ich fest überzeugt
wenn wir gemeinsam auf einer
nachhaltigere Zukunft in wortstand und
Sicherheit hinarbeiten
möge die Esche die ich heute nicht nach
Mittag in ihrem schönen Garten gepflanzt
habe ein kleines Symbol für das Wachsen
und Blühen unsere Partnerschaft sein
ich hoffe von
ganzem Herzen dass meine Frau und ich
lange genug leben werden damit wir in
diese wunderbare Stadt
zurückkommen und sehen können
wie unsere Baum gewachsen ist und damit
wir weiter unseren Teil zu dieser
kostbaren Freundschaft zwischen unseren
beiden Ländern beitragen können
kostbare Freundschaft das sind sehr
warme Worte von einem König fast schon
ungewohnt warme Worte wenn man mit
britischen Staatsgästen zu tun hat weil
da war ja eher der brexit und das Europa
feindliche fast schon ein großes Thema
was für Nachteile hat das auch König
Charles hat eben auch in der
bundestagsrede angesprochen mit dem
Blick auf die Ukraine ja sicher
der hatte interessante Weise gestern
also schon
Kanzler Scholz in Schutz genommen wegen
der lang anhaltende Diskussion über
Panzerlieferungen gesagt mehr oder
weniger das muss man ja auch verstehen
und die deutschen machen sehr sehr viel
für die Ukraine und dann hat er
natürlich den Bogen geschlagen zum
gemeinsamen Einsatz in den baltischen
Staaten der beiden Luftwaffen wo Sie
patschulieren und sorgen dafür dass die
Russen nicht in den Luftraum eindringen
und so weiter und so weiter aber
natürlich
die Briten wollen dass die Deutschen
nach wie vor kräftig Hilfe leisten für
die Ukraine und sind jetzt froh dass das
jetzt angefangen hat aber für sie hatte
es auch natürlich konkrete Nachteile und
deswegen schmeichelt der Charles das
auch denke ich weil die EU und
Großbritannien ist natürlich kein
Mitglied der EU mehr die EU hat massive
Waffen und munitionsprogramme aufgelegt
um der Ukrainer zu helfen und die
britische Wirtschaft geht Papa dabei
komplett leer auf der erlair aus das
sind keine Aufträge für die britischen
waffenfirmen munitionsfirmen und das ist
natürlich bitte aber letzten Endes
selbst verschuldet an soll diejenigen
sind die sind diejenigen die jahrelang
gehetzt haben gegen eine engere
Zusammenarbeit im Waffentechnologie
technologischen Bereich der EU das
wollten sie ja nie die wollten das immer
in die Natur Verlegen eines dorfregeln
und so weiter jetzt sind sie draußen die
Natur macht so nicht da liefert immer
liefen die Amerikaner was und die
EU-Mitgliedstaaten kommen zusammen und
liefern gemeinsam an die Ukraine und da
steht Großbritannien ziemlich isoliert
muss man sagen das ist ein Nachteil das
ist eigentlich noch denkbar dass Sie in
unserem Leben dass wir vielleicht noch
erleben das Großbritannien wieder nach
Europa geht und eine entsprechende
Abstimmung kommt also ich denke die
Historik Experten auf diesen Besuch
zurückblicken in einigen Jahren und
sagen das war so zu ein Wendepunkt wo
Großbritannien gemerkt hat es sind sehr
viele Nachteile mit dem brexit
aufgetaucht und wir mussten jetzt
einfach mal schauen wie wir sie regeln
können und wie wir näher an Europa
heranrücken der Oppositionsführer
kirschdamer der durchaus die nächste
Wahl gewinnen könnte der hat das so auf
seine Fahne geschrieben engere
Zusammenarbeit ich sage Danke für den
Augenblick an diejenigen die uns vom rbb
zugeschaut haben da geht's in 9 Sekunden
weiter mit dem Mittagsmagazin aber hier
Phoenix geht's natürlich weiter im
laufenden Programm mit Gramm Lukas
und wir reden weiter hier
in Phoenix die RBB Zuschauer die uns
jetzt zugeschaltet waren über anderthalb
Stunden für die Rede auch von König
Charles und gerade verabschiedet bevor
es in den Bundestag weitergeht der Saal
fühlt sich schon etwas aber es geht
nicht genau los um 13 Uhr also
verschiebt sich etwas ist ja auch klar
es gab genug Gesprächsbedarf auf die
Rede
er ist politischer als seine Mutter habe
ich den Eindruck in sein Reden er hatte
eigentlich immer Meinungen das muss man
ja auch sagen und in seine Rolle als
als schon Nachfolge konnte er sich dann
natürlich gewisse Maßen austoben und er
war in den vergangenen Jahrzehnten bei
bestimmten Themen die ihm wichtig waren
sehr direkt ja und das hat ihn natürlich
auch einen Ruf eingehandelt als jemand
der vielleicht
ein zuloses Mundwerk hat und sich nicht
beherrschen kann und so weiter und jetzt
das König hat er natürlich natürlich
eine eine ganz andere Position er darf
nicht politisch sein alles wird mit mit
der Regierung abgestimmt aber wie ich
vorhin erläutet habe denke ich sind zu
ein paar persönliche Akzente in diese
Räder eingeflossen die wohl nicht zu
verhindern waren durch Downing Street
weil sie so formuliert waren dass man
sie durchaus akzeptieren könnten eine
Tuch drüber wischen aber letzten Endes
bin ich mir ziemlich sicher dass der
seine
persönliche Handschrift da rein hinein
reagiert hat also denn insgesamt Lukas
mit Einschätzung zum Besuch in
Deutschland König Charles immerhin seine
erste Auslandsreise und auch die
Möglichkeit neue pflücke einzurammen für
sich als König aber auch für die Deutsch
britischen Beziehung danke für Ihren
Besuch bitte schön und im Bundestag geht
es weiter heute ist ja Sitzung im Plenum
und ich gebe ab nach Berlin zu meinem
Kollegen er hat schärfer
Heiligung bewaffnete deutsche
Streitkräfte ja da sind wir wieder meine
Damen und Herren und das